people hate Chris Paul
and I don't know if they've ever really
spoken to somebody who knows Chris Paul
well so what is it that you would say
about Chris Paul and why you think he
tends to be misunderstood
yeah
um we hated each other in college we
both talked about that openly before so
that's to each other to each other about
each other it did different articles
sometimes when you get on the team
together are you like okay we gotta talk
about how we really [ __ ] hate each
other because we have to get past it so
we we he resigned uh and then a few
other guys resigned Darren Collison
signed a one-year deal and then I signed
a four-year deal so we had this press
conference and it was really the first
time that we sort of had talked uh we I
think texted during free agency but it
was like so brief it wasn't a real
conversation so we talked there and like
I was kind of like I don't know how this
is going to go like is he is he gonna be
an [ __ ] to me like he's been an
[ __ ] to be by my entire existence of
knowing him
um and we both had gotten invited to
Brandon bass's wedding that summer so
Brandon was my teammate um in Orlando
originally then again with the Clippers
later on
but so we go to Houston and
I like saw him walking in the hotel I
was we were sitting you know I think we
were in the restaurant or whatever so I
texted him I was there he had Brandon's
wedding he's like yeah I was like come
down when you're ready Chelsea and I are
just waiting to go so so he came down
and we chatted for like two hours and it
was like oh I'm gonna really like this
guy I'm gonna really like this guy in in
some ways we are wired the same way
um I'm not throwing elbows into Jose
Alvarado's chin
I'm not that type of bad angle there I'm
not nut punching Julius Hodge I'm not
doing that but
it's all love CP it is all love CP oh
but yeah that's a bad angle on that
video Chris and I we we could we could
yell at each other this is why we could
yell at each other
we could disagree with each other on the
court and then we could go get dinner
after the game it was never personal
because I understood
that he just wanted to win and he
understood that I just wanted to win
yeah
um and so because of that we got along
really well and became very close
friends but when did you know like okay
we're friends like not just we sat in
this Lobby for two hours and we spoke
Scandal the television show yeah you
bonded over a scandal we would him and
Jada would invite Chelsea and I over
every week to watch Scandal and we'd go
and we'd sit in this theater room we'd
pour a glass of wine and we'd watch
Scandal that is hope for like weeks and
weeks and weeks